If you make people of their own accord they face their fears and the difficulties they avoid
Which they themselves know they must overcome in order to reach their goals
Or life that they would like if you could teach people that
That is to stand up to their problems and fears and confront them
Then they will acquire maturity and strength that has no limit at it stop. For example, ask yourself if for ten years
You did not ignore the things you were supposed to do according to your perspective of life
And your plans and plans that you planned for yourself, how will it be then?
Indeed, there are examples of great people who have come to this world and presented themselves as examples
Others have followed this approach for decades
That is, for decades they have been walking according to a method they have set for themselves
The result is that they have made themselves mature and powerful
They were growing stronger and more mature over time
There is no limit to this growth, ie growth on the level of self and personality
You can even say in part that the cause of your suffering is unbearable and that in fact you can overcome it
It is because you do not arrive as an individual for all you can be of strength and maturity
You yourself are aware of this fact and it is a disturbing and difficult fact to recognize
Or considering them
But it is a fact that includes a gospel and a promise because the meaning of this is that there is another perspective to the world
You can acquire it, and there are many ways to influence the world you can adopt
And make it so that the results of your adoption of this new vision better than before
The other point is to imagine if a number of people embrace this perspective and follow his approach
Because as human beings we have accomplished many great things
For example, more than 250,000 people will be uprooted from extreme poverty and around 300,000 people
The electricity will be delivered to them and that means saving large groups of extreme poverty
With an unprecedented rate and speed of human history, and these achievements have been achieved
For example, in 2000, the United Nations Organization
To reduce poverty between 2000 and 2015 and the targets were achieved by 2013
There is an escalation in the large disparity in income levels in many countries
This can be heard from sharp political debates but generally
The level of public income is rising and this is very great
In fact, we can achieve what we have achieved doubling times to an unknown extent
If nations unite and unite their efforts to achieve and achieve a specific goal
Because in my experience we only use about one-fifty percent of our capabilities
You can deduce it yourself, so I asked what the university students were asking
How many hours of your time are wasted in the day or the number of hours you lose per week
The usual answer is about 4 to 6 hours a day
These hours are lost between the useless study, watching videos
On YouTube and the wonder watching videos is not just not a desire
They watch them and do not even care about their content and that after seeing them feel
Regretfully because they saw her and in this story is lost about 4 hours
This total is about 20 to 25 hours a week
About 100 hours per month
This is equivalent to two and a half working weeks, half a year of work per year
Even if the working hour was estimated at $ 20 and is undoubtedly much more than that
Probably up to $ 50 if you consider deferred payment of salaries
If you put 20 hours a week, you lose about $ 50,000 a year
You are really doing it
And because you are unemployed, you lose fifty thousand dollars a year
You are a greater and greater disaster than I have done
Because I will not stay on earth as much as you will stay
So if your life is not as good as it can be
Ask yourself then what will happen if you stop wasting time and opportunities
Then you will know how effective and accomplished it will be
Likely to double to ten
Fold or more than twenty times what you are now
On Pareto's principle, it is not possible to predict the ability and effectiveness that people will have
Their ability and effectiveness will exceed the boundaries so that they are difficult to count
If we were to meet as a nation and unite our efforts, we would also stop spoiling things
Because this is something that people follow all the time
That is, they are not only doing what needs to be done to improve things
They deliberately seek to make things worse
Whether it is because they are hateful, resentful, arrogant, deceptive, or
Criminals or thugs or all of the above
Mixed, mixed and interconnected
If people really stop making things worse, then we do not know how much
The great improvement we will see just by stopping corruption
There is such a remarkable interdependence and congruence with our reality
Between both human weakness and society's imposed provisions and which as a whole are considered a cause
President in the suffering and also the failure of the individual to assume responsibilities
Responsibilities that he himself is aware of must bear
There is something else that deserves our consideration and it is one of the things that have a stake in
The discussions I offer to university students
As you know there is in our midst that thing called conscience and this conscience expresses
About himself with a sense or whispering voice
Who comes without timely introductions before offering a crap
Advising you not to take this foolish act
Then you can ignore his advice and choose to submit to your action
But what to do is what you have been warned to do
Above your head are the consequences that your conscience warns you of and then feels foolish about what you have offered
The consequences will be less painful if these happen to you by accident
Because you are the one who caused harm to yourself because you were aware of the price of taking that foolishness
You have been alerted to the consequences
But above all, she ignored everything and insisted on walking
The wonder is also in our complete ignorance of the source of conscience
And its presence in our inner and our senses, and we have no idea about this
And you may wonder if I have committed myself to the conscience of five
Or ten years what will happen to him at the time and what will be the status of the family
Which I will be and how will my social relations be and you should consider
The human relations that you make up on your own basis will be deeper and stronger
Of the ones you pose as you wear the mask
However, the person who is dealing with you and with you has a relationship
Will deal with you on what you are, whether on the level of good or even catastrophic aspects
This is a difficult amount but you can build a ground of understanding
Because your relationship is based on your own truth, there is scope to create this ground, but it can build
This means that you live on your truth and that you can create a healthy environment in your life and this in itself
A good foundation for a decision like having a child
Because then you can build a real and solid relationship with them instead of bringing them to cause them
Severe suffering Unfortunately, this is happening in many cases against children
The truth is deeper than that, because that is what I will conclude with
This is why I want to present some of what the nihilists wrote about sociology
Because, as you have seen, your destiny as the individual of your destiny is not only linked to you and what
If you achieve your compatibility with yourself and work to fix it, it is not dependent on your destiny as an individual and only
Your destiny is tied to the fate of those around you and those who are related to them and can say there
Nine billion people in the world by the way we will reach the limits of this figure and then the population will decrease
To return to seven billion people you will wonder who you are, you are just an atom
Central dust is 7 billion people so that's why
Which makes me see my decisions and actions very important but this perception and this concept is wrong
Rather, the closest thing to the truth is that you are a meeting point in a network that is interconnected
Of course, modern means of communication reinforce this
For example, you know at least a thousand people throughout your life
These people each know a thousand people
It means that between you and a million people is just one person
By connecting two people, you connect to a billion-person network of knowledge
It follows that your actions are not isolated but rather extended
It is like falling gravel in a pond that results in successive waves
That is, what you do exceeds your surroundings and reach the orbits
It is difficult for you to even absorb its consequences and effects
This requires that what you do or even avoid doing
All of them are of greater importance and consequences than you think
Taking this into account and thinking about it sign the individual responsibility so that each
An act of his actions must be weighed, and you can say, but there is a meaning in this perspective and that is better
To live a life of worthlessness
But ask yourself honestly if you had the option
Between living a life where you have no responsibilities and having no value
Or reflect the equation and live a life of the same
Meaning and value and bear the responsibilities associated with everything
As a personal image it does not seem obvious to me that people will choose
Life associated with the meaning, can say but the nihilists
They live in misery because of the lack of meaning of life and they are suffering pain
Yes, but there are advantages that characterize the nihilistic life of the absence of any responsibilities and this is the price of suffering
I imagine that it can also be motivated to choose nihilistic life
You can say that your adoption of nihilistic view is not a choice
But as a result of the collapse of values ​​and cosmic view
Which you believe in, and yes it is possible if you allow it to collapse because it is easier than resistance
And what the price is suffering is worthless and you can then develop sympathy and compassion of people
You and you also have the option to live the role of the victim, a role if we look at him altogether
It is not a bad choice, especially since the alternative is confrontation by dealing with reality and its obligations
And to follow the dictates of conscience, and the truth Solzhenitsen
He and others predicted that even though it is one of the most important personalities of that people
In the 20th century, if they had lived a life where conscience does not exist, they would poison society
And if there were a large number going according to this corrupt approach then you will see hell
You will see hell with your own eyes and you can read the Gulag Archipelago if you like
And you'll see a time when hell embodies the earth, and you can
Decide if you have the desire to visit so place
Or even this is the most important place where your family and friends take it
Unfortunately, part of that transformation happens in the 20th century.